what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Fantastic
Fest 2023 we are talking about a Stephen
King adaptation right now it is Pet
Cemetery Bloodlines with filmmaker
Lindsey Anderson beer hello and
congratulations thank you so much nice
to meet you I love Stephen King I love
pet cemetery but first I want to make
sure our audience gets to learn a little
bit more about you yeah I was looking up
that you studied neuroscience and
intersection of technology in society at
Sanford I had to write that down to be
able to repeat it what inspired you to
study that and then what inspired the
shift of filmmaking I always wanted to
be a filmmaker I was one of those
annoying kids who was like always just
turning in a movie instead of an essay
or something for school projects I
respect that
um but I always I loved horror and
science fiction and I just felt like
studying something in related to to
science could just be such an
interesting backdrop and stuff to mine
for my career later so you decide you
want to pursue filmmaking full force
when that happened what would you say
was the key to Bridging the Gap for
identifying the dream and making it
happen because I feel like I heard your
name for the first time on something and
then all of a sudden I heard it on a
million things and you really got going
very quickly I work uh like 18 to 20
hours a day if I decide to do something
I really really do it and I moved here
and I just never stopped working and um
just tried really gave it my all and
when I think that's all you can do if
you love something you just throw
yourself at it and have no regrets this
particular business I feel like that's
the only mentality you can have if you
want to jump into it yeah so you've been
you've been writing and producing but
this marks your feature directorial
debut selecting the right material is
the utmost importance for something like
that so why particularly pet cemetery
Bloodlines what did you think it was
about that material that aligned with
the skills you already had and would
maybe help you take those skills to the
next level yeah it's a great question
there was so much about it I mean first
of all pet cemetery was my favorite King
book when I was a kid so that was a
little bit of a a dream project but
specifically as a filmmaker I felt like
um even more so than all of King's work
which happens to like be a it's often a
mishmash of genres right like there's a
much more human element to it than a lot
of horror writers but pet cemetery
particularly is kind of a backdoor
horror movie it's a family drama that
becomes incredibly terrifying and I felt
like that Universe where you could make
a drama that just happens to be really
terrifying and in doing so also
kind of employ all of the filmmakers
kind of toolkits in a way that you don't
necessarily have to in other genres and
specifically for this project pet
cemetery is so much about confronting
death and I thought about things like
the Silence of death and the sound
design that I could use it my mind just
kind of started turning immediately
about how I could use all the different
aspects I love of filmmaking and I also
I love 60s music and that kind of hooked
me too there were just so many elements
that I felt like I could really dig into
the different areas of filmmaking that I
love for this particular movie so now to
build on that a little is there anything
about your experience making pet
cemetery that signaled to you that in
order to hone those skills even further
Sleepy Hollow would be the next best
film to make Sleepy Hollow you know
there are a lot of skill sets that are
similar in terms of its beloved IP it's
also the same kind of thing where when I
was doing Bloodlines I kept asking
myself when I was doing the rewrites
what would I want to know as a as a pet
cemetery fan what are the questions left
unanswered from the book and what are
the parts of the book that haven't been
explored in movies like you know for
instance
um the end of the book says that Judd is
the guardian of the woods and and um the
book says that Judd's experience with
Timmy baderman is the reason that the
evil is even targeting him as an old man
that we know so there are so many things
like that that aren't explored in films
and that a lot of a lot of the fans
don't know because they haven't read the
book or haven't read in the book in the
same for so much time Sleepy Hollow same
thing like the legends of Sleepy Hollow
are so rich and as I started doing
um research about the Hudson Valley and
true ghost stories I just I got addicted
to that too it's like the best possible
answer right there
um you brought up the rewrites you did
on the script can you tell me a little
bit about what you really embraced in
Jeff's version of the screenplay and
then what you thought you could bring
out of his vision to you know enhance it
but also make it purely your own yeah
um you know directing is such a personal
Endeavor so of course you know even if a
script is amazing and when you come on
as a writer director you kind of have to
make it your own so
um the the stuff that I really respond
bonded to in Jeff's material was just
the bones of the story in terms of a
Timmy baderman story being the lens
through which you explore An Origin
story
um and centering that around Judd and
when I came on
um it was it was such a he had written
such a fun slasher movie
um but I wanted to return it more to the
tone of the book in terms of
um the mix of genres the the drama the
comedy the the make I want my goal was
to make it really brutal and raw and
scary as but also hopefully have a
lot of human moments so just tonally
that was a focus of the rewrites but
um just the there are a lot of new
characters that I brought in and
um particularly the character of Donna
and and and Manny are so important to me
there was a version of Manny and Jeff's
script but he was a little bit more of
the um kind of comedic sidekick was
there no Donna in that there's no Donna
I can't imagine the character of Manny
without that connection to Donna now
yeah there was a character named Donna
but who wasn't Donna he she was just
like uh she was like a um she was a uh
yeah a heart a party girl but not but
not Manny's sister not Native American
um but
um one of the things I like to do when
I'm rewriting somebody is change as
little as possible if so I kept the name
the same but
um yeah repurposed the the character and
um I just I thought that that
relationship between the two of them was
so Central to my my version of the movie
that I wanted to make and also just
giving Native Americans more of a point
of view in the movie just given the
history of kind of mystical indigenous
and the Trope of the cursed land that
was associated with the property before
I felt like I wanted to refresh that
mythology show that you know what we
know about pet cemetery and the curse is
actually not what it is and and that
there's a lot more to discover and the
story we know is either an explicit
cover-up or it's just superstitions or
you know whatever it is and to be able
to do that correctly I felt like we
needed when I thought Manny needed to be
an equal hero with Judd and two I
thought we needed a also a female Native
American perspective as well as a male
not easy to add new characters to a
beloved book adaptation I thought you
did that especially well here having
seen the film I can kind of answer this
question myself I think but I am curious
from your perspective having gone
through this experience making the movie
because we have many Stephen King
adaptations out there many of them are
absolutely phenomenal some you know
people people want a little something
else than what they got so having done
this movie what is one do for adapting a
Stephen King novel and what is one do
not that you would recommend to another
filmmaker about to adapt some of his
work you know I I adapt a lot of Ip
because that's the business we are in
you know these days and I always
approach it the same way which is that
you have to honor the spirit of what the
original thing was and to me the spirit
is like the theme or the moral question
so you know for Pet Cemetery even though
this is a very different kind of film
than and some of the other pet
cemeteries and isn't just a small family
drama but examines a whole town
that central question of what would you
do for somebody you love is is Central
to the the kind of core of the story and
where the horror comes from and where
the comedy comes from and uh where the
drama comes from and so I would say do
leaning to what made that property that
property what is that essential question
or Essence to that thing
um I would say don't is uh
don't isn't is is an interesting
question I would say don't just do
something to remake it you know it has
to stand on its own it has to have a
reason for being I definitely can get
behind that one of the things that kept
sticking out to me about your particular
film is I I just love the idea of
finding a little corner that is hinted
at but not fully explored I think
there's so much opportunity like
especially with Stephen King's work
where it is so incredibly rich full and
detailed yeah I mean really just about
everything he's ever written I feel like
there is some sort of hidden area
somewhere that we've at least heard a
line or maybe a chapter about that is
well worth its own full story oh for
sure and I mean the Timmy baderman story
could be its own full story even if it
wasn't an origin story that told more
about the founding of Ludlow and and
that to me I was trying to bridge the
intimacy of the Timmy story with kind of
the the scope of an origin story for
Ludlow and not just Judd I have one more
do do not question for you because I
love hearing about working with animals
and that was one of my favorite things
to talk about on the 2019 uh pet
cemetery movie what is one do and one do
not for working with a dog actor oh
um
do not
um uh block off long periods to work
with them because they Tire very easily
unfortunately and you got to be kind to
your animals
um do go into it with an open mind I was
told how awful it is to work with
animals and I had a delightful
experience with all of my animals it was
uh definitely a number one Film School
rule do not work do not work with babies
and do not work with animals yeah but I
love animals yeah I do too I know there
were three dogs
phenomenal work for all of them to
highlight some more of your cast here I
always love asking a question like this
of all the roles in this Ensemble which
was the easiest to cast where it was
like the right person just magically
appeared but then of the bunch who was
which character was the most difficult
to find the perfect fit for
um Manny was the easiest to cast I uh I
just knew I wanted forest and I offered
it to him I do not blame you one bit
that was uh very very easy to cast I
mean all the other young younger roles I
watched a ton of tapes
and but the older roles for Duchovny
Greer Henry Thomas Samantha Mathis those
were those were actually very easy and
that they all came to mind first and I
was lucky enough to get my first choices
so another thing I love talking about is
a very bloody movie Magic it is it is an
Artistry that I think needs even more
credit than it often gets oh yeah
definitely of everything you filmed in
that respect on this movie is there
anything that above all else made you go
like my God I cannot believe that that
is what it takes to make it look like
that on screen in the finished product
Oh
hmm
um
and there's nothing that surprised me
really but I completely agree with you
there's so much like craft and Artistry
on so many different levels that goes
into this between uh the people who make
the Prosthetics the angles you choose to
film things from I think even more than
any other genre it's so so key what
angles you're showing when and why
because something becomes scary or not
scary depending on on on which way
you're showing it
um the the foot scene is so it was so
fun to film
it's a good example right there good
example it's a nice tease yeah it was a
really good one and not I mostly try to
do practical effects but that was one
where it was practical enhanced by CG I
feel like
um both practical and digital are
beautiful arts and when they're both
used well together yeah that is just
always the pitch perfect combination
when you can for sure I'm gonna get
greedy right now
um now that you've done one Stephen King
adaptation if you had the opportunity to
adapt another one of his Works which one
would you pick and why
I really
it that would be like choosing favorite
children I don't I I I love asking
questions that are formatted like
choosing a paper child yeah I uh yeah
I'm sure anybody who actually has a
child which is not me is like no that is
not at all like choosing a favorite
child
um uh but um there are so many I I love
and I would really have to I don't know
that there's any that stands out right
now that I'm like
I don't feel like
it's been done well or I don't feel I
feel I feel like there's like this whole
missing chapter the way that I felt
about pet cemetery
um where I felt there was truly this
chapter that hadn't been told that I was
excited to contribute I'm just trying to
speak this into existence because I know
it existed and fell apart but I Want A
Long Walk movie so badly so badly okay
let's put that into the universe I'm
just speaking it we manifest things here
everyone knows yeah now I'm gonna do the
obnoxious thing and ask you about maybe
one or two upcoming titles so you
already brought up that you adapt a lot
of Ip and I feel like it could be a
similar approach to something like this
but I am very curious with something
like Bambi because we're often talking
about with the uh the live action uh
adaptations like I guess the question
often is like why why do we need another
one so going back to how you describe
pet cemetery what is something about the
classic version of Bambi that you think
is important to hold tie to but then
also how are you going to answer the
question of why why do we need a new
version yeah well what's interest
interesting about Bambi to me is it
absolutely is a classic and it's a like
it's a beautiful love poem such Artistry
to it I do think there's an entire
generation of children who have never
seen the original and that's very
different from say little mermaid or
Aladdin or the you know the the 90s
Heyday films that they've definitely
already seen I can't tell you how many
kids I I've seen who who've never seen
Bambi which is such a shame and the
thing is it's such a gorgeous film it's
a little bit different Tempo than I
think
um modern audiences are used to and I
also think there's a there's there's a
treatment of the
the not to spoil the plot but there's a
there's a there's a treatment of the mom
dying that I think some kids some
parents these days are more sensitive
about than they were and yes in the past
and I think that's one of the reasons
that they haven't shown it to their
children but I do think that there is a
way to update Bambi and our our take on
it was
um did give a little bit more of a scope
to it and I just think that to be able
to bring it to life for kids these days
in a way that maybe they relate to a
little bit more would would be of
service to the original uh Lord of the
Flies you're obsessed with uh Luca
you're producing that movie what can you
tease about what makes this movie his
version of that story compared to any
other interpretation maybe we've seen
before oh yeah it's it's it leans so
much into psychological horror and um it
it's so rich in character drama as you
would expect from somebody like him
um but it's it's scary it's just like so
une it gives you so much unease reading
it and I think it Taps into a more
current version of it than we we've seen
before
um just I think some people have tried
to tackle that property in a way that
doesn't really resonate to now and I
just I think that the whole approach has
been very fresh and refreshing I lie
I'll just ask my last one your Star Trek
movie yeah is it is it still going
forward I feel like we haven't heard
anything about it in like a year I don't
yeah it is it's still on the tracks it's
uh right answer again it's
um I love that project and it was
another one that I had to hop off of to
direct this movie
um and then that was a hard thing to do
but um which was uh but I love that
everybody involved with that project
that right there is the type of problem
you should where other opportunities
come up and you have to let some others
go I have very high hopes a lot of
people out there are going to appreciate
your spin on pet cemetery and exploring
that corner that was underdeveloped
before and then also can't wait to see
your Sleepy Hollow movie as well
congratulations thank you so much and
thanks for taking the time